hi they reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch this
trailer Star Wars Jedi fawn or Cal's
mission trailer count your Chester but
before we go into this video we got a
sponsor today and that is coin Master
what is coin master you ask why only the
most downloaded app game in the UK for
2019 Wow America to hear that we needa
bucker up as soon as possible coin
masters a social adventure game that
allows you to travel through time
visiting mystical lands collecting coins
building villages and raiding your
friends you can also collect special
cards test your luck in tournaments and
raise epic pets to help boost your
skills in combat the game has so many
awesome worlds in over 20 million
players inhabiting them so now is a
great time to jump in seriously there's
a tournament going on right now right
now so get those rewards you can check
out coin master today using our special
link down in the description box and pin
comment it's free to download and if you
use our special link you'll get an extra
300 thousand coins and 50 free slots
pins to get you started on your journey
what are you waiting for get that coin
Master yo
[Music]
okay shut that thing off and perhaps
perhaps some seat
[Music]
no you don't trust me but we have a
common enemy and a common cause
ascension
oh my god
[Music]
whoa sliding mission Co the force on
Xbox one I feel the force everywhere I
go oh yeah it's in your blood
midi-chlorians wills is this doing Kevin
Feige
produce uh yeah definitely this is his
he had an actor in mind and it was
Cameron Monaghan Cameron Monaghan and
Deborah Wilson I really hope this game
lives up to the hype I hope I cry when
Cowell dies at the end of this game it
would only make sense for him to die
right I like the time wish this takes
place right after Revenge of the Sith
you know after order 66 has been infused
with a few things I recall about Revenge
of the Sith yeah and and yeah it's an
interesting timeframe to kill old Jedi
and the character that I'm most
interested in is actually Deborah
Wilson's character because from what
I've read up on that she's supposed to
be the mentor to saw Guerrera see where
he got it she seems like she's a
completely different kind of character
as opposed to saw Guerrera maybe because
he had a physical handicap about man you
know I never watched the show that he
was originally portrayed in seeing the
the chemistry between her performance
and Cameron Monaghan's and Deborah
Wilson who I did you from MADtv that's
where I associate her personnel Oh
Howard she's from could be very
incorrect trying to go off memory here
but I'm pretty sure she's our MADtv oh
that's fun to be able to talk about
performances in video games I mean that
this is the first time we've seen real
actors doing mocap and lending actual
performance elements to a game but I
feel like that is a trend that is
becoming more and more focal and we're
having games that are probably gonna be
more driven by that appeal as well and
so yeah it kind of bridges especially
for a game that comes out of a movie
universe it kind of bridges that and I
know that with mediums that expand the
Star Wars universe a little bit more
outside of the films you can get a lot
more world exploration and more creature
exploration but they seem like they're
really thrown down for creature designs
in this game the game doesn't feel like
a horror game
it doesn't feel scary but the designs of
the creatures and having to fight them
that looks scary I feel like there's
gonna be a just an inherent and
of intensity being that you know you're
being hunted you know they're trying to
kill all the Jedi and you got to lay low
but you're also yeah fighting these
creatures and stuff like that you are on
these missions so I have to imagine that
yeah well not being like survival horror
I feel like intensity is gonna be a
pretty big element of this game oh
absolutely yeah and the character that I
think the second sister is what they
call her is trained by Vader we got a
lot of progressiveness in this video
game is it or you have a female
character villain and then you have a
female mentor yes but it's still led by
a white guy so we're a oh-kay people
nothing to worry about here woo hoo
we're trump on the brink of impeachment
we need to make sure we're safe right
now that's right we need healthy orange
haired white men we can get don't bring
politics into my Star Wars no don't ever
political why would you do that you are
in the space nazi saga but anyway just
making jokes people the mark of cinema
on these games is interesting like this
is the one time I think I've ever
watched a game trailer and thought to
myself I would watch maybe just like a
one of those you know Slee you know I
only make like the CGI Resident Evil
movies every now and again yeah I would
watch a Star Wars video game movie kind
of sooner than any other video game kind
of movie because this does feel like you
get to have your cake and eat it too you
get your you know cool intriguing plot
line but you're also gonna get to live
in the shoes of just exploring these
worlds and stuff and it seems like
they've thrown down pretty heavily on
the story aspect I mean video game
plotting I cannot imagine how hard that
must be a but they've made a big deal
about the writer doing the story for
this game so that's something that I'm
glad to hear about cuz it's not what I'm
using about for big property tie-in
games well for Star Wars games like this
one from per se they do care a lot about
making sure they got a really great
story at hand that does seem very
present like I'm immediately a mess in
the Cal character maybe because I'm
walking off
camera Monahan as Jerome in that show
it's an interesting thing with video
games when they model a character after
an actor that people love because for
some reason that does play hidden - and
I don't think it makes a difference for
people who you know are not familiar
with the actor but when you are familiar
with the actor it does make the gameplay
a lot more exciting and there are
elements of this game that feel a bit on
the heroing side of things I wonder if
that's gonna attempt to fill in any
potential gaps that are there because in
Revenge of the Sith I'm not as familiar
with the storylines of the game but in
Revenge of the Sith you know they
dispatched the people to kill all the
Jedi and he's like one of the last
surviving Jedi members and it seems like
he may be the last Jedi he's one of the
last gen but I wonder if it will fill in
any potential gaps or the fact that the
the Inquisitor trained by Vader herself
will fill in anything for Darth Vader
because the end of Revenge of the Sith
he dons the suit we don't have any of
the story lines in there of when he's
you know training anyone this is for
sale all that it's a few years after
Revenge of the Sith did Vader just
immediate like okay I need to start
mentoring some people you know I'm
pretty soon afterwards I've achieved my
final form and now it's time to build my
evil army because that time you get to a
new hope it's not like he's got a whole
bunch of people he's trained in the arts
of the dark ways of being it you know
the dark Sith him yeah Vader will make
an appearance here and and if he does
how much Vader will play into this game
well I know one thing and that's that
there's gonna be a Chewie appearance at
the very least you get to go to Kashi
which is like the Chewie plan at least
you'll get one cute and cuddly level
full with characters and stuff you
recognize from the films specifically
maybe it'll tie in to the Christmas
special that is actually that you get to
celebrate Christmas in the game oh
that's cool yeah if you play during the
holiday you remember like in Metal Gear
where you could set the clock and affect
the game this if you're playing around
Christmas you get to uh chill in the
wookie planet this may take place in a
long long time ago in a galaxy far far
away
but Jesus is Jesus of people it just
makes sense the real force its prayer
through God that's why we do that thing
in church where we're like the force be
with you and also anyway guys are you
excited for Star Wars Jedi fallen order
leave a comment down below you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Bell thank you to coin
master for sponsoring this video for us
yes I like to end this on a page of the
day shout out for a man named Jay in
Valente Jay is the tenth letter of the
alphabet it n is the 14th letter of the
alphabet add that together and that's 24
and that's how old you look in that
profile picture of yours you are a sexy
beast and I think you would look even
sexier in like a stormtrooper outfit a
Slave Leia outfit just with a lightsaber
just just strategically placed for
tastefulness yeah or you go whatever
this is yeah Thank You Jan for being a
part of our patreon page you've been a
top supporter for such a long time I
hope your love you adventuring but yes
please pose in a photo with a lightsaber
mirroring your genitals any coach